you know people I think they're very
hesitant to ask me about him and they're
like is he okay and he's honestly like
he's no different physically than any of
the other kids Jimmy Kimmel shares a
positive update about his five-year-old
son Billy who's undergone multiple heart
surgeries one of them just days after he
was born they did an echocardiogram
which is a sonogram of the heart and
found that Billy was born with
um
a heart disease Billy's doing great he's
a perfectly normal well I shouldn't see
he's normal he's not a normal kid he's a
weird kid but his heart is fine it's
just he's a little screwy that's all
we're worried about right now but he's a
uh he's doing great he still has to have
another surgery he can play sports he
doesn't want to but he can he uh you
know he's always dancing and jumping
around and we wrestle all the time but
um he's fine you know he's really except
for what's going on with his heart he's
perfectly fine the talk show host opened
up to ET at the Children's Hospital Los
Angeles Gala the event raised money to
support Hospital patient care and
research with help from celebs like
Jimmy Chris Pine and Justin Timberlake
Children's Hospital here in Los Angeles
is it's a just a great place for parents
to bring their kids when it's needed but
also it's a great place because they
train doctors and nurses from not just
all around the country to go all around
the world world so it really it's a
place where they come they learn how to
do this and um and it helps everybody
across the whole country not just in La
there are some bad things about being
famous and there are some good things
about being famous and one of the best
things about it is that you can shine a
light on these people who really are the
stars I mean you know I mean when you
can do something for somebody's kid they
become the most important people in the
world and to me that these people are
and just I mean the idea that we would
do anything else other than everything
we can to help them keep doing this for
so many I mean I hear from so many
people now that my son was at Children's
Hospital who contact me before they go
in there before it and I always say to
them I said listen I you know yeah
somebody I know I'll call before him but
you're not going to get treated any
different everyone's going to get
treated very well like a VIP at this
Hospital because that's just the way it
is there
[Music]